find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
good luck ralph and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice of this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa
91-a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call this
number 271-3600
in the event of the public the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned
and rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff
that are on the meeting assisting us
jennifer four
our committee researcher is before us
right now and
to from everybody here i'd like to say
thank you very much jen and then i also
want to put a special thank you out to
our previous chair mel miler
um mel unfortunately we never had our
get together at the end of that season
last year
where we usually go have a little meal
together but
accept our just appreciation for what
you went through
and you hung in there and thank you
uh please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by
roll call vote uh i don't believe we'll
be taking any votes but that's in my uh
speech right here let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call
of attendance i'd like to ask that our
clerk who
is barb shaw barb do you have
representative shaw do you have a list
attending
okay um i'll read down through the list
of the committee members at this time
and upon hearing your name would you say
present and please uh
uh inform us as to where you are
and uh whether you're there in your room
alone or you have
like i do a cocker spaniel and a
grandson running around behind me
um glenn cordelli
present i am home and uh my wife and
dog might be running around in front of
me
thank you representative barbara shaw
i am home and i have a
five-year-old grandson on zoom in the
kitchen
and uh my husband is in the cellar or
someplace
representative baum i'm here at home i'm
representative allard present
i am home uh in my sanctum sanctorum
and should remain that way but
occasionally a dog or my wife might pass
through
did i didn't hear you very much well
there um
yes i i said i'm home alone in the wilds
of loudon
how copy thank you colonel
uh represent deb hobson
good morning i'm here and uh my family
is
outside of my office i'm in my office
with my dog
present i'm home alone in my office and
my
my husband's outside somewhere i don't
have no idea where
oliver ford hello say i'm president
i'm present but i i
can't seem to get the speaker going okay
i saw you were the first one to log on
um represent uh jen can you
try to work with him a little bit uh
representative erica lane
i am president at home with my three
boys in the house they'll be around
and my really fast comcast connection
isn't working so i'm over cellular so i
hope we don't have any communication
problems
thank you thank you representative julie
saty
representative miler yeah i'm here
um uh i'm at home and uh but i will be
running out to the doctor during the day
but i'll try to stay tuned in though
i have earphones and stuff so thank you
very much
representative mel miler good morning
i'm here in kentucky new hampshire by
myself my wife may be
back and forth out of the room but i'm
basically here by myself thank you
thank you mel representative david luno
good morning mr chair reporting from
hopkinton with ozzy the long-haired
dachshund
i've heard that name many times before
this summer
representative patricia cornell i i
can't hear
it says down here that he's thank you
linda
uh representative arthur ellison uh
president i'm a home alone here in
concord new hampshire
thank you representative sue mullen uh
i am here this morning with you
representative uh
dialing in from bedford with an
intrusive cat
and my wife may be in and out of the
room
thank you representative doug lay
good morning mr chair i am home alone in
jaffrey
new hampshire thank you very much and
representative stephen woodcock
welcome my name is chairman uh home with
my wife and my dog the dog will back my
wife will be fine
that sounds like we're going to have a
fun committee thank you
um i'd like to take a moment and just uh
does everybody have a copy of the agenda
i i sent it out by way i think jen also
sent it out by way of
email it was in a welcome letter that i
said
um it going through it it indicates that
from 8 45 to 9 15.
rick